December 5, 1948
in New Mexico,
two different sightings
by aircraft that
were in the area at the time.
The first was an Air
Force C-47 transport
plane which was in the vicinity
of Kirtland Air Force Base.
The pilot and other
crew saw this object
that was greenish luminescent,
totally unidentifiable.
And then shortly after that
there was a commercial flight
that radioed into
Kirtland Air Force Base
as well, essentially do
you have this on radar?
Are you tracking
anything like this?
We're seeing something
very, very unusual.
That was the beginning of these
so-called green fireballs.
And, in fact, throughout
December of 1948,
more than half of the
remaining days in the year
had sightings of
these fireballs.
I remember it happened in 1948
in Albuquerque, in the region
around Albuquerque,
which of course
was ground zero for a lot
of the atomic experiments.
So people were concerned.
One of the first questions
that people were asking
is are the Russians doing this?
And a lot of scientists--
the scientists themselves that
were charged with studying it
were often witnesses of it,
and a lot of military personnel
were certainly witnesses
to this phenomenon.
But the reality is that there's
no evidence that the Russians
had anything to do with these
so-called green fireballs,
and no one was able to find
out what these things were.
There were theories that these
were meteors of some sort.
The top meteorologist
in the country, a man
named Dr. Lincoln LaPaz did a
great amount of study of this
on behalf of the
United States military
and government of these
so-called green fireballs.
And the problem is LaPaz never
found any evidence that these
were meteoric in any way.
There's no impact sites
that were ever found.
There was no other evidence,
anything to come to show
that these were meteorites.
So that was a problem.
JACQUES VALLEE: Dr. Hynek knew
Dr. LaPaz and respected him,
and that was something
that we discussed.
But there was no
obvious explanation,
and it didn't
continue after 1948.
So the question is still open.